♪♪
Narrator:
IT'S CALLED A JETWING,
A HUMAN-SIZED, JET-PROPELLED
CARBON-FIBER WING
THAT TURNS THE PERSON WHO WEARS
IT INTO A FLYING AIRCRAFT.
THAT'S BANANAS.
WE'VE ALL SEEN HANG GLIDERS.
YOU JUMP OFF A CLIFF,
AND YOU FLOAT DOWN.
NOW IMAGINE FLOATING DOWN
WITH YOUR OWN JET ENGINE.
I LIKE IT.
Haislip:
JETWINGS LOOK FREAKIN' RAD.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY A THING,
'CAUSE THEY KIND OF LOOK LIKE
A THING
THAT WOULD JUST POP UP IN
A "MISSION: IMPOSSIBLE" MOVIE.
THIS IS BETTER.
Narrator:
JETWING PARTS INCLUDE
FOUR STATE-OF-THE-ART
JET ENGINES,
CARBON FIBER,
A MULTIPOINT HARNESS,
THREE PARACHUTES,
AND A FRIEND WITH A HELICOPTER.
THESE GUYS ARE TAKING FLIGHT
TO THE NEXT LEVEL --
TO THE NEXT, SCARY LEVEL.
YOU DON'T WANT TO JUST DIVE OUT
OF A PLANE
WITH A JETWING ON YOUR BACK.
OH, IT MIGHT LOOK EASY
IN A JAMES BOND MOVIE,
BUT, UH, NO.
STEP ONE IN THIS PROCESS
IS GETTING COMFORTABLE
WITH SKYDIVING.
AND NOT JUST SKYDIVING,
BUT SKYDIVING WITH SOMETHING BIG
ON YOUR BACK.
Narrator: BEFORE ATTEMPTING
JET-PROPELLED FLIGHT,
JETWING PILOTS USE
NONPOWERED TEST WINGS
TO GET ACCUSTOMED
TO THE MECHANICS OF GLIDING.
THEY EMPLOY THESE
WHILE SKYDIVING
TO LEARN HOW TO USE THEIR
BODIES' POSITIONS TO STEER.
THIS JETWING DOESN'T HAVE ANY
TRADITIONAL STEERING CONTROLS,
SO YOUR BODY ACTS AS THE RUDDER,
AND SMALL CHANGES IN YOUR HEAD
OR YOUR ARMS AND LEGS
STEER YOU OFF IN ONE DIRECTION
OR THE OTHER.
YOU DO WANT IT TO BE STRONG
ENOUGH TO SUPPORT YOU IN FLIGHT,
SO YOU WANT IT TO BE AS LIGHT
AND AS STIFF AS POSSIBLE.
Narrator: WINGS ARE MOLDED
FROM CARBON FIBER,
PAINTED WITH EPOXY, AND DRIED.
WING SECTIONS
ARE THEN FASTENED TOGETHER.
FOUR-GALLON FUEL TANKS
ARE ATTACHED TO EACH WING.
CARBON FIBER'S GREAT
BECAUSE IT'S LIGHTWEIGHT.
IT'S 80% LESS DENSE THAN STEEL,
BUT IT'S INCREDIBLY STRONG.
IT'S ACTUALLY STRONGER,
POUND FOR POUND, THAN ALUMINUM,
WHICH IS THE STANDARD
FOR AIRCRAFT.
Narrator:
A JETWING'S THRUST IS PROVIDED
BY FOUR SMALL BUT POWERFUL
JetCat P 400-RX ENGINES,
EACH WEIGHING JUST 7.7 POUNDS
BUT CAPABLE OF GENERATING
88 POUNDS OF THRUST
WITH TURBINES SPINNING AT UP TO
98,000 REVOLUTIONS PER MINUTE.
THE TWO ENGINES ARE ATTACHED
TO EACH SIDE OF THE JETWING
AND SHEATHED IN KEVLAR
FOR EXTRA PROTECTION.
LISTEN, I'VE TRIED PARASAILING.
IT'S A LITTLE SLOW.
I THINK ADDING A JET ENGINE
TO IT
MAKES IT A WHOLE NEW BALLGAME.
BUT YOU'RE SERIOUSLY RISKING
ANGERING THE BIRDS.